This lecture is about the feedback in
text retrieval.
So in this lecture we're going to
continue the discussion of text
retrieval methods.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the feedback impacts retrieval.
This is a diagram that shows the
retrieval process.
We can see the user with typing the
query.
And then the query would be sent to a
retrieval engine or search engine.
And the engine will return results.
These results will be shown to the
user.
After the user has seen these results.
The user can actually make judgments.
So for example, the user had said this
is good and this document is not very
useful.
This is good again, etc.
Now this is called a relevant judgment
or relevance feedback because we've got
some feedback information from the user
based on the judgments.
This can be very useful to the system
we learn.
What exactly is interesting to the
user.
So the feedback module would then take
this as input.
And also use the document collection
to try to improve ranking.
Typically it would involve updating the
query so the system can now rank the
results more accurately for the user.
So this is all relevance feedback.
The feedback is based on relevance
judgments made by the users.
Now these judgments are reliable, but
the users generally don't want to make
extra effort unless they have to.
So the downside is that it involves
some extra effort by the user.
There was another form of feedback
called pseudo relevance feedback or
blind feedback, also called automatic
feedback.
In this case you can see.
Once the user has got without all in
fact we don't have to involve users so
you can see there's no user involved
here.
And we simply assume that the top
ranked documents to be relevant.
Let's say we can assume top ten as
relevant.
And then we would then use these.
Assumed documents to learn and to
improve the query.
Now you might wonder how could this
help if we simply assume the top ranked
documents to be relavant well.
You can imagine these top ranked
documents are actually similar to
relevant documents, even if they are
not relevant.
They look like relevant documents, so
it's possible to learn some related
terms to the query from this set.
In fact, there you may recall that we
talked about using language model to
analyze word association to learn
related words to the word "computer"
right, and then what we did is we first
use computer to retrieve all the
documents that contain computer.
So imagine now the query here is a
computer right?
And then the results will be those
documents that contain computer and
what we can do then is to take the top
N results.
They can match computer very well and
we're going to count the terms in this
set.
And then we're going to then use the
background language model to choose the
terms that are frequent in this set,
but not frequent
In the whole collection.
So if we make a contrast between these
two, what we can find these that would
learn some related terms to the word
computer?
As we have seen before and these
related words can then be added to the
original query to expand the query and
this would help us bring documents that
don't necessarily match computer but
match other words like a program and
software.
So this is the effective for improving
the search result.
But of course, pseudo relavance feedback
is completely unreliable.
We have to arbitrary set a cut off, so
there's also something in between
called implicit feedback.
In this case, what we do is we do
involve users, but we don't have to
have asked users to make judgments
instead, or even the observe how the
user interacts with the search result.
In this case, we're going to look at
the clickthroughs so the user clicked on
this one and the user viewed this one
and the user skipped this one and the
user view this one again.
Now this also is a clue about whether a
document is useful to the user.
And we can even assume that we're going
to use only the snippet here in this
document.
The text that's actually seen by the
user instead of the actual document of
this entry.
The link there, let's say in web
search may be broken, but then it
doesn't matter if the user tried to
fetch this document, because of the
display, the text.
We can assume these display.
The text is probably relevant, is
interesting to user.
So we can learn from such information
and this is called implicit feedback.
And we can again use the information to
update the query.
This is a very important technique used
in modern search engines.
Will think about the Google and Bing
and they can collect a lot of user
activities while they're serving us,
right?
So they would observe what documents we
click on, what documents will skip, and
this information is very valuable and
they can use this to improve the search
engine.
So to summarize, we talked about the
three kinds of feedback here.
Relevance feedback, where the user
makes explicit judgments.
It takes some user effort, but the
judgment the information is reliable.
We talk about pseudo feedback where we
simply assume top-ranked documents to be
relevant.
We don't have to involve the user,
therefore we could do that actually,
before we return the results to the
user.
And the third is implicit feedback,
where we use click clues.
We don't we involved users, but the
user doesn't have to make explicit
effort to make judgment.